and i'll even take it a step further as
it relates to bam like i well you're
friends with him
right right right and like i'm really
close with the bam situation
and my experience was i didn't even meet
him until we were filming the second
season of jackass
and and uh before like uh
before we were filming the second season
of jackass like
i got my hands on his cky tape this is
after the first season had already aired
and i got my hands on his cky 2k video
which is one
something he distributed all by himself
which was so [ __ ] mind-blowing to me
because i was trying to get in people's
videos
he was like [ __ ] that he produced it
edited it distributed it all by himself
and it was incredible and i was so
[ __ ] jealous of this kid dude like
my buddy was making a porno and as i'm
watching this at my buddy's house
he's banging this chick on camera i'm
just like pounding on the door dude we
gotta go
like like i was so i was like we got it
i got to do something rad i'm so jealous
of bam
you know i just jumped off the sixth
floor balcony into a pool
and and uh we were on liquid acid that
day and i went and
threw myself off a bridge while walking
on stilts it was just my response
to being jealous of bam you know like it
motivated me to want to be
like more rad to take that and go and to
revert it and go i'm going to take this
energy right now
work harder yeah i'm jealous of you and
thank you for motivating me to get that
[ __ ] stilts off bridge bit
you know in in in a bigger sense it's
like
he was younger than me he was more
successful than me he was a better
skateboarder than me
just way richer more creative better
looking
you know like across the board bam style
yeah tasted music the [ __ ] kid had
everything sure
i remember i remember just being like
the [ __ ] what's that he's got a [ __ ]
lamborghini
what the [ __ ] right he he like when we
were just
recording the [ __ ] second season of
jackass he had just been to the audi
dealership wasn't sure which one he
liked best so he bought two at the same
time
and i was flat [ __ ] broke
i was so jealous of him but like over
the years
it was okay to be jealous of him i was
just a [ __ ] fan of him i was a fan of
him
and then now like to see him go through
the times the tough times that you know
whenever he's on
tmz it's been bad you know it's been bad
and like i
i tell him that you know i i've told him
straight up
to his face like dude like i was always
so jealous of you and i just i
deeply deeply want to be
jealous of you again you know don't let
me not be jealous of you you know like
it's a really beautiful statement
yeah that's yeah it's funny man
it's funny it's funny too because you're
willing to allow when you're a fan of
someone
you're willing to allow them to [ __ ] up
because you want to see them succeed
when you were at your lowest your fans
were like come on stevo
you can't go out like this sure and
people are saying that about bam right
now
you can't go out like this man i got
when he's when he goes
i remember this post so vividly i think
i texted you
when van was like man i'm in brazil i
just got robbed
what are you gonna do you know knives at
my i'm gonna have a beer a knife up my
throat i was like you don't need to tell
me the story just have the beer man we
get it
yeah dude